thierry amouroux porte parole du
syndicat national des professionnels
infirmiers bonsoir thierry amouroux
merci d'être avec nous edouard philippe
qui promet donc que le quotidien des
personnels soignants l'hôpital
changerait dans des tout prochains mois
votre quotidien donc ça laisse présager
des changements concrets
la crise du coc vide aura au moins servi
à cela selon vous vous êtes relativement
confiant alors on est nous sommes
confiant dans le soutien de la
population qui s'est manifestée tous les
soirs à 20h et donc qui a obligé le
gouvernement à évoluer un peu sur ses
positions
mais malheureusement pour l'instant on
en reste aux grands principes c'est à
dire que aujourd'hui c'était une grand
messe visioconférence avec 300 personnes
et ben on a eu droit à un exercice de
style un cours magistral
simplement on aurait préféré plutôt que
d'avoir un prof de français qui fait une
perte à sion un prof de maths qui avance
des chiffres précis de combien nous
allons être heureux ont revalorisé
combien de lits vont être ouverts et
combien de personnes vont être recrutées
dans les hôpitaux
c'est les trois choses que l'on
attendait et on n'a pas de réponse
chiffrée donc alors le seigneur ne fait
qu'ouvrir il a ouvert aujourd'hui parmi
les axes il ya celui de l'investissement
massif ça veut dire quelque chose pour
vous avez bon espoir que le nom de lee
augmente notamment avec cette crise 1
qui a mis en valeur en exergue
manque de lits évidemment de nos
hôpitaux publics est effectivement tous
les français ont pu constater que la
france n'avait que ça me lit de
réanimation alors que l'allemagne en
avait cinq fois plus et du coup ils ont
eu quatre fois moins de deux morts donc
nous on attend qu'on rouvre des lions
n'a pas arrêté d'en fermer depuis vingt
ans des petits hôpitaux des des
maternités des urgences ont été fermées
les uns après les autres
voilà il est temps de rouvrir un nombre
de lits conséquent pour répondre aux
besoins de santé de la population qui
entre-temps a augmenté en taille on est
8 millions de plus qu'il ya 20 ans nous
avons également une population
vieillissante ya de plus en plus de 2 81
ans à d une population qui a également
développé plus de maladies chroniques
donc il est important d'avoir une
réponse au nombre de lits et au nom de
saignant parce que en allemagne il ya
trente fois plus d'infirmières qu'en
france alors il ya aussi évidemment on
le sait la question des salaires qui
vous préoccupe particulièrement pour
arriver à peu près à la moyenne
européenne il nous en faudrait en tout
cas c'est ce que demandent les soignants
sauf erreur de ma part pas votre
syndicat mais en tout cas la majorité
300 euros par mois ce que ça vous semble
réaliste aujourd'hui vous y croyez à
cette augmentation conséquente
oui le le chiffre de 300 euros et est
partagé par tous y compris par le
gouvernement parce que si les études
internationales qui ont montré le
différentiel entre le salaire infirmier
français et le salaire infirmiers moyen
dans l'ensemble de l'union européenne et
donc nous sommes sous payés de 3,11
euros par rapport à nos collègues des
autres pays ce qui pose un problème de
recrutement d'attractivité et du coup il
ya des postes qui restent vacants parce
que ben être sous payés en sous-effectif
pour travailler dans des conditions
déplorables je rappelle que pendant qu
vide on a été un certain nombre à porter
des sacs poubelles sur le dos faute
d'avoir des idées sur blues manquent de
masques également donc effectivement ça
fait quand même réfléchir
donc on attend une revalorisation
salariale le importante
on espère qu'il va pas être étalés non
plus sur sur 20 ans si on nous sort vous
allez être valorisée 2 300 euros mais
vous aurez 15 euros de plus chaque année
jusqu'à atteindre cette somme on en
prend pour 20 ans donc ça ne correspond
pas aux attentes non plus dernière
question c'est nicole notât qu'on
connaît bien les 1210 ta liste qui est
chargé en de sa conviction de négocier
c'est plutôt bonne chance au pont vont
pas du tout non c'est une personne très
contreversé indépendamment de ses
positions très très hostile aux salariés
lorsqu'elles étaient responsables de la
cfdt
elle a également présidé une
organisation qui s'appelle le siècle qui
rassemble des des hauts fonctionnaires
des responsables de médias des
responsables politiques ultra libéraux
donc non c'est un très mauvais signal
c'est même une provocation pour les
salariés
donc la mobilisation va continuer plus
que jamais avec notamment la journée du
16 juin
oui nous sommes une douzaine
d'organisations a appelé à une journée
de mobilisation populaire donc c'est pas
une grande manifestation nationale qu'on
cherche à avoir des des mobilisations
locales autour des 1000 hôpitaux
français et des 7200 ehpad pour que
chacun dans sa ville dans ce puits se
manifester son soutien aux soignants
donc le séjour 1 à l'heure qui
conviendra et dans le respect des des
gestes barrières mais une multitude
d'actions locales pour montrer que sur
l'ensemble du territoire la population
soutient toujours
les soignants et nous invitons également
la population à faire pression sur le
maire qui présidait l'instance qui gère
l'hôpital et auprès des parlementaires
qui chaque année vote le budget des
hôpitaux et qui diminue nos moyens
chaque année donc il faut vraiment faire
pression auprès de vos élus locaux merci
à vous thierry amouroux d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt français